je t'ai dit deux mots dans le couloir tu
te souviens ouais d'accord maintenant
non non non
non tu ne peux pas
manger et très sérieux on s'amuse plus
maintenant d'accord sinon c'est dans mon
bureau à 16h mais on se verra à 16h dans
le bureau maintenant oui tu l'écoutes
pas tu les écoutes pas maintenant on va
parler d'un sujet écoute qui est grave
et qui s'appelle les traumatises et les
chocs d'accord maintenant d'abord on va
revenir un petit peu sur l'historique
j'accuse TF1 de prendre des personnes
avec une faille un peu fragile et de les
mettre dans des conditions dangereuses
ça veut dire que toi quand tu as été sur
TF1 moi il y a quelqu'un qui m'a envoyé
la vidéo donc je me suis tapé tout
l'après-midi à écrire à faire la vidéo
et analyser la situation
c'est pour toi Amandine
donc quand TF1 apprend des personnes ne
parle pas quand je parle quand il y a
faim tu vas hurler à chaque fois quand
TF1 prend des personnes et que la
personne savent que la personne c'est
une chez toi une petite faille tu vois
c'est pas méchant une petite faille
voilà on a tout ça oui on en a tous
c'est bon
et la petite faille c'est que tu faisais
déjà du libertinage
on n'est pas libertin non j'ai pas dit
avec voilà
libéré mais pas liberté
tu passes à TF1 tu vas connaître gloire
et beauté toi ici on connaît gloire et
beauté non non tu vois c'était parfait
c'était parfait et après qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans ta tête après quand tu
quittes TF1 qu'est-ce qui se passe à ce
moment-là c'est ça l'histoire ça
commence là ton histoire moi j'ai
visionné la vidéo de qui c'est qui me
l'a envoyé là sur Youtube là je sais pas
quoi
déjà je peux me permettre je peux me
permettre avant de poursuivre sur TF1 on
n'a jamais connu on a toujours été la
famille la plus critiquée non mais
d'accord oui mais tu as été mise en
avant
on était à la fin
après
une famille nombreuse
pour l'instant on a toujours été un peu
voilà vraiment on va dire une caricature
c'est vrai qu'on a toujours on a
toujours été décrié de par un moi mon
caractère celui de mon mari parce qu'on
nous en dit pas l'un de l'autre
néanmoins on a toujours sincère et
honnête et nous-mêmes face au
téléspectateurs donc c'était très bien
on est d'accord tu étais
parfaitement elle vous demande ce qui
s'est passé après non mais il faut
construire l'histoire tu comprends oui
voilà donc après après de ce que moi
j'ai vu et que j'ai analysé tout
l'après-midi sur la vidéo
à chaque fois ça va pas y arriver
laisse-moi finir donc donc après
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous allez
découvrir moi ce que j'ai vu sur la
vidéo c'est un couple d'abord qui s'est
c'est quoi de qui de quoi
la vidéo déjà
voilà d'accord je sais déjà ce que vous
allez me dire
alors regarde non c'est pas une raison
elle veut déchirer le monde a raison tu
es jeune tu as raison d'accord mais 5
minutes pour moi oui donc si tu veux à
partir de ce moment-là moi quand je vois
la vidéo je vois un jeune enfin un jeune
ah oui un couple
qui ont une boîte de prod ils ont une
boîte de prod il y a des caméraman il y
a des acteurs d'un seul coup mais écoute
moi Amandine essaye de suivre quand je
parle je sais justement une boîte de
base c'est à dire c'est un truc tout est
bien organisé vous présenter des
produits c'est pas méchant ce que je dis
non j'ai dit quelque chose de mal oui
mais on va dire business on va se faire
déchirer on va lui dire tout doucement
hein donc un business ça te va un
business alors qu'est-ce que
quand il y a le début de l'interview
vous montrer les ustensiles comme tu
vois quelqu'un montrera l'aspirateur
vous voyez en fait
laisse-moi analyser parce qu'à la fin il
faut que j'arrive d'accord merci
donc si tu veux moi ce que je vois pour
faire plus rapide je vois quelqu'un un
homme et une femme peu importe qui ont
créé une entreprise boîte de prod on va
dire what the prod c'est plus rigolo
tu changeras après ensuite et qui
présente leurs produits etc etc
parallèlement à ça un couple qui a dû
être un peu éloigné pendant l'histoire
des enfants et qui se retrouve
d'accord et qui se retrouve donc c'est
positif voilà et et après c'est ça et
après il y a tout un enchaînement où
c'est une situation qui a été créée ça
oui j'aime pas le mot business mais
c'est tu vois c'est quelque chose qui a
été établi on a des commandes on a
beaucoup de commandes non mais ça
pourrait mais c'est un business tu vois
ou les choses elles sont comme ça bien
établies
Géraldine Mathieu hier qui disait non
mais s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
c'est insupportable
pense que c'est dramatique pour les
enfants qu'est-ce que vous dites-vous
Raymonde ce que c'est pour ça que je
vous inviter soit je voulais avoir votre
réponse voilà donc tu vois d'un côté il
y a le TF1 après il y a le business et
puis après il y a les enfants d'accord
alors par exemple
tu veux tu me la donnes merci
je me fais laminer il y a deux jours je
n'étais pas là et hier je me suis fait
insulter devant mon fils par ces deux
énergumènes
pour les enfants avec moi Amandine parce
que si tu croises pas une attention 5
minutes on va pas y arriver très
attentive au contraire alors on y va les
enfants
si on prend les grands schémas de la
psychanalyse tel que moi j'ai pratique
un enfant à qui on dit pas les choses il
peut effectivement voir les images il
peut être traumatisé maintenant faut
faire la différence entre un traumatisme
et un choc ici ils ont tous été choqué
tu vois la différence maintenant un
enfant il peut être que c'est traumatisé
ou choqué un choc c'est immédiat il y a
quelque chose tu vois tu réagis
immédiatement un choc
différent mais on est tous choqué ici
mais après on raisonne tu comprends on
est grande contrairement à toi d'accord
bon ok donc maintenant d'accord
maintenant les traumatismes c'est c'est
c'est quelque chose qui se passe qui
n'est pas expliqué qui est sous silence
qui est pas dit qui est pas raconté et
qui va faire une espèce de masse et qui
va se réveiller tôt ou tard tu as 18 ans
20 ans c'est d'accord maintenant on a
quand même du sexe dans l'histoire donc
ça fait une légère différence donc
les traumatisme alors ici tout le monde
a été choqué donc tu dois accepter qu'il
soit choqué
de personnes qui sont d'accord
c'est une expression d'accord donc
maintenant si tu veux pas le discours
enfin quand même
laissez-la parler vraiment digne les
gens disent qu'on comprend rien c'est
quelque chose que tu vois que tu vois
sur lequel tu mets des paroles etc et tu
vas faire une autre histoire d'accord
maintenant si on explique à un enfant
papa maman vont travailler très tard et
rentreront tard le matin ils peuvent
comprendre d'accord maintenant tu as un
enfant qui est grand qui est dans sa
bulle parce que je pense en plus de
temps HP donc il est dans sa bulle
tranquille c'est pas grave oui mon fils
est surdoué donc
il est mort sa bulle
insupportable alors on va parler Léo
s'appelle
bien les surdoué le surdoué il va tout
donner pour ses parents il les adore
donc quoi que vous fassiez lui il sera
toujours d'accord avec vous attends non
non mais pas d'accord sur mais quand tu
arrêtes pas de la ramener il peut pas
être d'accord non plus tu comprends
alors à un moment faut être un peu doux
alors que mon fils il a été personne pas
toujours d'accord avec toi parce que ça
arrête pas de la ramener au bout d'un
moment écoute 5 minutes
sera vécu comme quelque chose qui fait
une masse dont l'enfant fera son
histoire d'accord et évidemment que ça
sera un traumatisme selon selon selon
les événements une mère qui rentre tard
c'est un trauma le père qui bat sa femme
c'est un trauma il y en a plein des
traumas d'accord bien sûr d'accord
maintenant là il y a une petite
différence c'est qu'on est avec une
histoire de sexe tu veux pas dire non
bah oui quand même
j'ai vu les vidéos c'est pas un dessin
animé
après soit les enfants ils vont voir
alors il y a quelque chose tu sais par
exemple les parents sont dans la chambre
avec un enfant et l'homme il dit à sa
femme parce que en général c'est l'homme
qui a demandé mais il y a aussi des
femmes et il dit t'inquiète pas s'il te
plaît je te parle d'autre chose il y a
pas que toi je te parle d'autres cas
d'accord les parents dorment à côté d'un
enfant et ils disent c'est pas grave
l'enfant il dort on fait l'amour c'est
très traumatisant donc il y a des choses
il y a plein de tu vas être d'accord
avec moi c'est pour ça écoute-moi 5
minutes
c'est plus facile que le tien donc si tu
veux c'est ça il y a plein de
traumatismes voilà maintenant le sexe
c'est quoi c'est visuel c'est c'est les
images qui vont rester c'est pas les
paroles pas beaucoup d'accord donc on
est d'accord c'est les images c'est
censé soit les enfants voilà merci soit
bien avec moi on va donner du sens à ce
que tu fais soit les enfants ils voient
les images et les images ils vont les
stocker dans la mémoire entend bien le
danger visuel quand il surprennent c'est
pas une chanson
non mais
sur une scène en direct par exemple un
enfant
l'image elle va rentrer dans la tête de
l'enfant écoute bien
réel Amandine on va se faire un schéma
l'image
telle qu'elle soit on parlera après
c'est quoi l'image elle va rentrer dans
la tête de l'enfant d'accord il va
grandir il va grandir il va vous les
enlever
insupportable elle rentre dans la tête
de l'enfant
mémorise après il rencontre une femme
il y a l'image de sa femme et après il y
a cette image qui vient se superposer et
il sait plus avec qui baise est-ce que
tu comprends le problème oui je crois
que là elle a compris
[Rires]
donc on parle des traumatismes
évidemment ça concerne pas toi tu es
dans ton business mais tu vas venir avec
moi sur la route toi Raymonde est-ce que
tu penses donc toi
en résumé tu penses que c'est
traumatisant pour les enfants je pense
que les images elle reste marqué elle a
beau avoir expliqué
j'aimerais bien attendre Alexandre un
peu Alexandre qu'est-ce que tu en penses
que en fait des images
quand même ça va circuler
même pour les plus âgés
[Musique]
boule de cristal
voilà
la télé tous les jours le jour où il y a
des
des camarades n'importe quoi
tu veux faire parler d'accord
le jour où il y a un des parent d'élèves
dans des camarades de classe de tes
enfants en supposant de tourner ils sont
plus à l'école ils sont grands story
dis-moi
quelle heure il est normal en fait que
les enfants sachent ce qui se passe chez
les parents et
toi tu dis toi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une fille de 21 ans j'ai un fils de
18 ans je suis à poil dans un canapé
merci
Amandine elle a un côté enfant qui est
très en souffrance il faut avoir
comprend oui mais c'est ça côté on peut
pas faire d'Anaïs ici Géraldine du coup
gratuitement quand elle veut mais je
peux pas faire une analyse devant tout
le monde merde défaillante ma chanteuse
je te parle de son histoire j'ai compris
un cheminement mais qui a fait un de
avant on devait parler tout échange donc
tu vas écouter je t'ai dit c'était sûr
qu'avec dire elle m'a dit pas la même
chose si attention ne change pas les
choses je t'ai dit dans le couloir qu'on
devait tout analyser jusqu'à arriver à
ce que tu voulais toi d'accord tu as
toujours pris soin de mes enfants